i will say this so being racist to the
guy who missed it really makes
missing it so much easier oh that's true
like i'm glad i missed it yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah i thought we in this
together we all part of the same country
you don't think i'm disappointed too and
now you're gonna make me the black guy
who's not english and you think i did it
for my own
you know crazy objective that i'd like
to like check off my list [ __ ] you
yeah i'm gonna miss it next time too
kid's 19 years old the last guy i think
is
so insane yeah 19 years old his first
thing the kid wants to deliver first
professional
penalty kick ever like for club or
country first time
you imagine why just because he's gay
saying all kinds of fun
no it's just a coaching issue it's like
a leadership coaching issue it's like
honestly [ __ ] up that like
you put this kid in the most pivotal
position because it's the last pk like
regardless of what's happening like
yeah it might not get to him if there's
something that happens but like you're
going to go through all five pk's but do
you
choose do they get to choose who goes so
why didn't you order but like and who
goes
i was looking at it and um and there
were certain guys that were playing like
that harry kane guy
yeah like who's legit dude but i guess
he's a little bit older
yeah and i was i was reading and they
said basically he wasn't doing [ __ ]
during the game
but you they want to keep them on the
pitch because they thought it could go
to penalties
yeah and that he was going to be good at
the penalty yeah but why not make that
guy go last make him your fifth kick
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
100 because you either got a score for
like the win or you miss it and you lose
like it's all on that last one and if
you're like if you're a vet
and you miss you got enough experience
to be like oh to be okay and you're
probably not gonna play that much longer
anyway if you're 19
you might have ruined this kid's life
yeah he missed one kick and now he's
just [ __ ] shattered confident
shots don't get why would you put a 19
year old there who's never done that
yeah
like with penalties it's like an
experience and meant like a mental game
yeah like everyone can kick the ball
every player on the field can kick it
into the goal like it's
easy but it's all mental shouldn't
everybody be tight at the coach
yeah i mean i think so yeah but people
aren't smart enough to think that they
see the guy missing and there are it's
already a pretty racist place so that
black kid missed it [ __ ] him let it all
out no
the black guy's like athlete your job is
to kick the ball and a goal like
you're here because you're good at
kicking the ball on a call yeah yeah we
can't make the
excuse to oh he's 19. he should know
better type of thing yeah
this is what you get paid millions of
dollars a year yeah that's what you get
paid to do but this isn't even for
people it would be a better strategy
but at the same time it's like bruh hit
the free throws
yeah you know what i mean like if you're
an nba player you got two shots to win
the game
hit the [ __ ] free throw sure the
stupidest thing just go straight
the [ __ ] jumps left or right
every just goes straight
yeah why haven't they figured that [ __ ]
out yet so i was obviously and that
goalie is the best
well both of them were great i feel bad
for the england goalie because the
england goal he saved it a couple times
yeah he had a crazy game oh he was on it
robbie
had a funny ass tweet he said i relate
to goalies because uh they too complain
when they have to do their job
any time there's a kick on goal a goalie
after he saves it
screaming at the defenders like they
were also trying to stop him
yeah like democrat gets to sit in front
of the net the whole game and jump four
times
yeah defenders are running up and down
the field every single time
one time you gotta do your job and it's
like how the [ __ ] could you make me work
right yeah goalies are like uh goes like
the jamaican morgan that works at cvs
yeah you're like you know i'll just
hey can i check this out
[Laughter]
yeah but it's just [ __ ] up from the
coach i also think it's a leadership
issue on the team like if you're the
captain of the team
you can't be letting this a younger kid
you should kick the ladder
the last thing should always be even if
because that's the thing some of the
guys aren't as good at penalties but
it's like
let me if it's gonna if someone's gonna
[ __ ] it up let me be the one responsible
for that yeah
[ __ ] yeah because he did shoot he did
kick it [ __ ]
yeah it wasn't a great penalty the
penalty like like we were watching the
game here the other day yeah
and some of these dudes kicked it with
the utmost confidence bros it was
unbelievable
they blasted it to like the top corner
yeah maguire had an amazing pk
that in that shootout he was one of the
guys that went up the england ones yeah
and so it's like you see that
and then you saw what the last kid did
and i think the last kid again
i'm a complete novice casual when it
comes to soccer but the way he kicked it
is
don't [ __ ] it up yeah he kicked it as
hit it on goal
hit it on goal and hopefully the guy
jumps the other way yeah it wasn't great
where i've seen ones where it's like
there is a two-inch window for that ball
to even enter the goal
yeah top corner the [ __ ] doesn't
even get it in
who hits the pole son what
what i believe because he got it right
he guessed that's so stupid about that
goddamn sports
you just have to kick it in yeah
somebody you know what's weird in those
moments like
it's kind of fun to root for the goalie
because he's the underdog
oh yeah and when you don't have any
attachment to either side like i'm going
all right you got this
it's really impressive to stop a pk yeah
yeah it's really impressive
cause people say the hardest thing in in
sports is hitting a baseball
i think the hardest thing in sports is
stopping a penalty kick
you don't think so both sports are [ __ ]
stuff but
the ability to do it no but one's just a
guessing game the other one actually
takes skill
i hear what you're saying that's
interesting because he's jumping
whatever way he's going so his body is
here you're saying the percentages could
be
lower for for stopping a penalty kick
but since it's not a skill based
decision it's a guessing game yeah
that's that's true hitting a baseball is
not guessing it's no good it's like
nah it is sometimes some keepers try to
watch the uh
like watch like where his feet placement
is like where the knee goes
i mean a little bit but at the same time
at the end of the day you're guessing
also baseball is kind of guessing no it
smells good no it's not it's a fraction
of a second where you see the ball
coming because i've played before and
you can tell if it's going to be in the
strike zone or not but also ted williams
would say he could see the laces on a
baseball
and based on how the laces were spinning
that's
the ball would drop and go in a certain
direction so that's going to be a
curveball as a slider like that's next
level vision right
but um all those things are kind of cool
i remember a tennis thing i showed you
where andre agassi was talking about
playing this guy
horseback yeah some tennis player and
then in tennis you also have a split
second to know which way is the serve
going yeah and he said every time on
this side of the court he would serve
wide or down the middle
he would stick his tongue out right
before he served i found him watching
tape yeah and then i never told him
and then years later i told him but he
used to always just know on that like
so they're always looking to tell him
yeah just stick his tongue out like this
they said that like and i don't know
what goalies do you know in their off
time
but i assume it's this that they were
going through
footage yeah and doing your that's the
crazy thing about like professional
penalties is that you have all the
penalties this person has ever taken in
their life
and then you see what the england
penalty lineup is because both the teams
have penalty shootouts in the same
tournament
so you're like okay this is what their
lineup was before this is where they all
went last time
and then you can see all their pks from
their club years and you're like okay
sixty percent of the time this player
goes live going that way
40 times he goes right corner like and
then you just have to kind of just take
the percentage like
also i bet you can have nerds that are
crunching it and go he goes right
if he's following someone who went right
he also goes right yeah
like there's data to it statisticians on
a team like
my buddy has one on his team and
literally all they do is go okay
he shoots 80 percent of his shots from
this part of physicality where does he
start the penalty kick like is he more
if he's more left he goes right if he's
got six people to memorize and then they
give you 70
chance that he's gonna go right you go
okay seventy percent i'm going
i'll take that and then you're the
shooter and you're like okay i know this
guy knows what i do
do i change it yeah cause he's gonna
change it or do i go the same way and
then if i change it i risk missing it
because this is not what i'm used to
yeah because i normally hit it right in
this one spot it's soccer song
it's like a super she's like super high
stakes rock paper scissors yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's exactly rock paper
scissors that's exactly what it is
trying to figure out the psychology of
this [ __ ] literally exactly
that's the skill it takes about how
frivolous it is like yeah
that's why it's the most popular game in
the world yeah they entered them
yeah it's simple in that way like in the
same way like the most popular
gambling games are the ones where
there's no skill
roulette roulette is so much more fun
like sitting there
grinding out poker i want to be there
for four hours a bunch of guys smoking
cigarettes
[ __ ] sunglasses your buddies with you
like hey can i play like no you can't
yeah you don't know how to play
that throw it on hit we're going to the
club crap yeah let's play
yeah yeah luck i get it i was watching
it
i was watching it at a um a bar that was
for english fans oh son
they were devastating they looked at you
crazy after no no
i didn't even know i didn't beat them
i can't tell but it was just funny like
they started crying there's a couple
people started crying i'm like
come on son for a euro like stop it like
stop important
that's awesome it's all that matters or
maybe olympics but i don't even think
the good guys play anymore
but it was at the same time they had the
euros and concacaf so uh
argentina one yeah or south america i
mean those are the two best regions in
the world
right right but america doesn't care
about tournaments that aren't the whole
world
like we just want to win the world we
don't care about your little section
like that's adorable
yeah that was an unbelievable tournament
soccer slash football is incredible it's
cool but it's for
it's little like it's like when a
college team wins you're like all right
that's adorable but you know why penalty
kicks are cool is because it's the most
high-stakes [ __ ]
we love steaks dude human beings love
high stakes that's
so [ __ ] high stakes yeah it's this
kick
right here five of them it's over quick
so the pressure mounts each [ __ ] kick
it's just like
is game soccer it's hard man there's not
a lot of reward you you
really ought to care about the team but
penalty kicks i don't need to be
invested i can care you don't need to
know anything about it it's like
okay they're inbound on the ball game's
tied if he makes the basket they win the
game like it's the most basic
carnival games yeah it's basically yeah
it is it is good
we're gonna do a penalty shootout though
yeah we should do it straight down the
middle
did y'all ever do that as kids world cup
this is so weird i remember i was
hanging on my homies plays he went to ut
now there's a story that i was like oh
we're all kind of the same
my uh my in rohit you met him at the
wedding uh
i was he was a ut and i went to go visit
him he had his apartment complex like
friday night everybody's getting drunk
we see this white party we see this
indian party we're all just drunk
outside and then my homie roy when he
gets drunk he's like real just [ __ ]
wild
he just this is while the world cup is
on he just slams the soccer ball down in
front of a white guy and he just goes
world cup let's go and the white guy's
standing in front of a wall i swear to
god
god doesn't say a word he just takes his
shirt off gets into goalies
and then we start doing india versus
america and we start doing a whole world
cup right there five kicks
we lost at the end and wrote was [ __ ]
devastated but it was just such a funny
thing of like
dude penalty kicks we all [ __ ] care
about this that is true